[Applaus]
sehr geehrter präsident sehr geehrte
damen und herren es ist nicht die
regierung und nicht ihr klima kabinett
und auch nicht ihre ideologischen vor
toner von den grünen die sich hier um
deutschland irgendwie verdient machen
es sind auch nicht die mainstream
journalisten und die klima ist erika die
hier überall sitzen sie alle sind die
zerstörer unserer wirtschaftskraft und
damit die zerstörer des deutschen
sozialstaat und mehr nicht verdient
verdient um deutschland das machen sich
die pendler die jeden morgen mit ihrem
diesel zur arbeit fahren das machen sich
die familien die kinder bekommen die
mittelständler die arbeit schaffen und
millionen von arbeitnehmern gerade auch
im kleinen und mittleren
einkommensbereich die das geld
erarbeiten was sie für ihren klima waren
zum fenster hinaus schmeißen meine damen
und herren höhere lebenshaltungskosten
durch mieten energie und höhere
kraftstoffpreise bedeuten für viele
arbeitnehmer und rentner den unterschied
zwischen gerade noch mit dem geld
auskommen und am ende nichts mehr haben
für viele selbstständige bedeuten sie
den unterschied zwischen
selbstständigkeit und insolvenz für
viele bedeutet der klima waren die
gefahr des wirtschaftlichen niedergangs
oder gar der verarmung für diese
menschen meine damen und herren steht ja
fdp-fraktion für diese menschen spreche
ich heute hier im deutschen bundestag
war dazu niemand anders mehr bereit ist
es sind die menschen die sie auch von
der union im machtpoker verschachern und
das sind die menschen die gerade die
deutsche sozialdemokratie nach hartz4
zum zweiten mal hier mal ich verrät und
das eine schande
es sind menschen
die unter dieser regierung leiden denn
diese regierung ist der
erfüllungsgehilfe der grünen klima sekte
und sonst leider nichts
es sind menschen aus der mitte des
deutschen volkes dem sie geschworen
haben seinen nutzen zu mehren und
schaden von ihm abzuwenden
seitdem aber in deutschland der
nüchterne politische sachverstand dem
regierungs dogma greta diktiert merkel
leider gerade nicht da pariert gewichen
ist verläuft die ware spaltung in
deutschland zwischen den grüne bahnen
besserverdienenden und denen die sich
nicht um einen erfundenen weltuntergang
gedanken machen sondern die sich darum
gedanken machen müssen wie viel geld am
monatsende noch auf dem konto ist meine
damen und herren
allein 2017 kostet in die energiewende
die privaten haushalte 9 milliarden euro
die kanzlerin sagte 2011 die eeg-umlage
solle den damaligen stand nicht
überschreiten sie lag damals bei 3,5
cent heute liegt sie bei 6 cent mit dem
klimapaket wurde auch die reform des eeg
und damit die entlastung von familien
angekündigt
im ersten schritt sollen nun familien um
sage und schreibe 70 cent pro monat im
durchschnitt entlastet werden das ist
noch nicht mal die einstmals propagierte
sprichwörtliche kugel eis meine damen
und herren das ist ein hohn und ein
schlag ins gesicht der bürger
allein 22 prozent des strompreises
zahlen wir für die teure und unnütze
energiewende
deshalb fordert die ard auch eindeutig
fed mit dem erneuerbare-energien-gesetz
die bepreisung von co2 macht alles
teurer lebensmittel mieten
dienstleistungen ein auto besser gesagt
ein e auto kann sich auch nur der
leisten der etwas geld beiseite legen
kann das können durch ihre politik viele
nicht mehr
die grünen fordern ja schon jetzt einen
höheren co2 preis ich fordere die
regierung auf machen sie endlich schluss
mit diesem ideologischen grünen unsinn
den sie hier vertreten und gerade sie
von der union sie fordere ich auf hören
sie auf in bund und land mit
linksextremen öko populisten zu
paktieren um ihre eigene macht zu
erhalten sie auch nicht kehren sie zu
einer verantwortungsvollen bürgerlichen
politik zurück vielen dank herr schönste
brümmer lachen sie
sie machen sich lächerlich